what have we been doing for the past
hour we've been
going to the police
[Music]
[Music]
station righty we just got off the
airplane where are we
we just got off the airplane and where
are we now in boston
massachusetts fast and we're invested
everyone's bored you did so good on this
flight he did he did really really good
is he doing better and better you're
like the season traveler now don't you
know that yeah don't you know don't you
know wrong wrong state wrong city and i
did so good my body did so great good
job no uh panic attack so i felt it
coming because as soon as we got on the
airplane the lady right in front of us
was like kind of like a karen yeah she
was just like so we had like a singing
like a music toy it's kind of like this
one but different and
it was kind of loud but i had it on on
the lowest volume setting and she was
like
your toy is so loud can you lower it
like i have earbuds and i can't even
hear what's going on yeah she didn't say
it nice she just said like straight up
like can you just get rid of that toy
because it's bothering me and so i got
so i'm like all right well it's either
you listen to this music or you hear him
cry so it's already at the lowest volume
like i don't know what to tell you lady
like come on yeah and it was so
ridiculous because then right after that
like they started like turning on the
airplane stuff and we're at the back of
the plane so it was loud you couldn't
even hear the music anymore yeah like if
you just waited like two minutes you
didn't have to like it would it wouldn't
have been a problem yeah like she would
have to make it all weird and
uncomfortable and now i'm like okay now
i'm pissed that i'm behind this lady and
then like when we landed she had her
they kept telling her to move her seat
up because i was directly behind her and
then they kept telling her to move her
seat up and then she was just like oh
yeah she didn't move it up so the right
one we actually stopped i'm like is your
seat all the way up and she's like i
don't know is it and then she pushes the
button and i push the
chair up and yeah you pushed hard dude
you're like i'm going to show you no
actually that was i didn't do that
it looked like you slammed it forward no
it literally i just moved it the
movement was exaggerated to the point
where i guess casey received that
message but i wasn't trying to be oh
maybe she's really sensitive because
when she pushed it back it also like
shot back too like where you're it
almost hit you in the face
oh she's being passive aggressive
because he said something the seat was
making causing problems i feel like i'm
spending too much time complaining about
this lady yeah she's now worth it
and luca did so great he was just kind
of like a tiny bit fussy at one point
and that was it he was cracking up
though the whole light what every corner
for three minutes we still haven't said
what the point of why we're in boston
it's that's hilarious
so we're in boston for carrie and
diana's wedding well actually
they're getting married in rhode island
but we stopped in boston this is part of
the trip yeah it's part of the trip the
whole trip is for carrying diana's
wedding and the plan like the whole trip
itinerary is we stop in boston for a few
days explore boston and then head over
to rhode island have wedding activities
in rhode island and then we do a road
trip all through upstate new york we
stop in syracuse and albany i forgot
which one comes first and then also
aurora and then we go all the way to
buffalo and we're gonna see niagara
falls
so that's the plan for this trip you
know what's crazy i counted how many
states isaac visited like during the
summer
or how many states luca has seen so far
in his life well because isaac has the
most because he went on oh right he went
to lachlan with his dad yeah and so
counting them all like by the end of the
summer he would have visited nine states
including california wow just like
california texas florida nevada arizona
massachusetts rhode island new york oh
wait oh my god eight i don't know why
you counted wait did i say california i
did oh my gosh eight myself
look he's been sucking on his bottom lip
so now he has a rash down here
that's new that was new that wasn't
there this morning look a baby look baby
alright so my baby brother is getting
married on this trip we're out here in
boston to celebrate and i'm super
excited baby brother's getting married
and uh
probably the second most important
wedding i've ever been to in my life
[Music]
imagine you getting married
[Music]
mr mouth breather over here
is he a lot bigger since the
hi do last remember me
you remember me
that was really good
let me go help all right so we got a
suburban but can we fit everything what
do you think this is the biggest one i
could get the biggest car we can rent
and we still got a lot of luggage and a
lot of people to
carry let's see what we can do
welcome to new england my favorite
region of the continental u.s
all right so carrie's like a big nerd
when it comes to the crossbows and stuff
loves coming out here in boston very
fitting for him to get married out here
and this is the place you wanted to take
me to like this bar there's a drink here
there's a really nice cocktail here with
uh the one i showed you with gazpacho in
it oh
it's really good give me one of those
[Music]
[Music]
all right we are in our airbnb
he's like i'm feeling better now
i'm feeling better now look at that guy
he's just staring at us so this is our
airbnb and i'm trying to figure out
how to
fix our luggage because we brought two
big luggages yeah one carry-on for all
four of us true we packed a lot of stuff
i think we did pretty good for four
people true especially with the baby
considering the baby considering we're
packed for a wedding as well i brought
my suit isis got a suit just got a dress
we got dress shoes we've got uh hair
luca's got a suit i love the east
coastness of this room though look at
these windows i really really like this
i really like boston you want to move to
boston should we start looking at boston
we can't afford bus we can't afford to
california we can't afford boston yeah i
don't know but i really like
the vibes out here like how old it is
yeah there's like
there's culture oh my god oh careful
yeah look this is how i passed all of
our stuff
so the packing cheese oh you know what
the last time we went to vegas you said
you'd show everyone how i know but no i
can't because i didn't but we never just
show them the packing cubes but look
this is all of our garment bag
yeah the super wedding
suits and all that it doesn't have a
closet
this one's hit
this
we have this
is our room too yeah that that one i
think this one's oh that was isaac's
room this is our bathroom then this is
our wing of the house
we got a wing of the house what about
the master suite uh or the primary suite
i'm sorry primary room their primary
room it's a pretty big bed but the room
is small oh yeah it's not even the bed
nice you get to stare at this guy
but yeah i get to talk about my package
oh yeah
so anyway look this is like all the
packing cubes that we got going this is
all isaac's side this is yours and i
purchased packing cubes for each member
of the family and they're each color
coordinated per member so casey's gray
isaac's navy blue i'm beige and luca is
baby blue very cute yeah so we were able
to fit all my clothes in two packing
cubes yeah same with me very nice and so
now we get to just live out of the
packing cubes rather than living out of
the suitcase exactly
i love it yup you are such a genius man
of the house is needed again
[Music]
check this out
bam what are we looking at i got my
jacket i feel like you're you're this is
the equivalent of a of a
mechanic showing me the engine of a car
i'm like oh check it out i'm like what
am i looking at so luca has this
portable high chair okay we got a
backpack diaper bag we got these are my
my things right here
this is lucas stuff we got diapers for
days and his stuff and i have his
inflatable bathtub
pro tip is to always pack the most
important things in your carry-on okay
because it's happened to me before where
you lose your check-in check-in luggage
okay don't be showing our cup oh yeah
what are you talking about i was just
following the action you know
professional camera man just follow the
action
yeah so important things
is
the cubes that actually contain our
clothes so this is why i separated them
i was actually trying to not bring a
carry on and just only have check-in in
just this bag
but then it was overweight so i had to
i had to bring in a chicken right and
isaac stuff didn't fit so that's why he
has his own over there but yeah this is
the
packing situation oh and then let me
show you once i actually open it do you
see how everything's like in a file
cabinet kind of folding that's very
impressive look at this you see every
outfit everything in our closet is like
this too because you can see it all
that's true beautiful
i'm really proud of this that's true
because otherwise someone like me if if
you do it the conventional way like the
way i grew up putting clothes on top of
each other i would always wear the same
tube shirts
wash it put it back on top right from
the top again
it's so cute
are we sleeping separate
that's how we did it in orlando true
you're lucky you get your
my
[Music]
you get the picture we get the picture
we get to go swim with bobo
all right it's a brand new day in boston
actually we're not even in boston yet i
just found out we are in a place called
jamaica plains
in the boston area yeah it's just like
us like we don't live in actual downtown
l.a but we live in
true but today we are going into boston
and we're gonna go explore have some fun
all right so if i'm traveling with my
family
anywhere we go doesn't matter where in
the world we could be on mars
i guess it's not in the world but we
could be anywhere
but we could be on mars we're always
gonna have to track down some chinese
food especially dim sum and try it out
but luckily for us boston's also got a
pretty cool like
chinese population chinatown area
[Music]
yeah this reminds me of that one
that one restaurant we went to hong kong
where it was like modern dim sum or
something where they actually made like
little
creatures
yeah they actually have a mango pudding
that's shaped like a duck coconut
pudding
like a bunny
and minion dumplings
cute which one are you looking forward
to
that's a good question because i want
both of the puddings i didn't really
care for the dumpling you got a minion
stand no i i just are your disney girl
right
it's not about the characters oh not the
actual like coconut and mango flavor oh
okay
the bunnies don't move though no i'm
just gonna use my hands because that is
so cute
sprinkle
oh you killed it
[Music]
yeah
yeah yeah
[Music]
it's very soft
[Music]
now
we
are on a tour of the city of boston we
are in boston common that's the term i
believe just parked we're at this park
first impressions of boston is that it
reminds me of san francisco
without the homeless luca was just
looking that way and just going
and then
were like it's probably the ghost making
them smile yeah i got probably so i'm
like who's visiting us right now luca
who do you see there's probably dead
bodies under us all over paul revere is
he saying the british are coming i'm
actually i should have done this before
but i'm now downloading the freedom
trail
self-guided
because he's our guide tour today
that's a great guide right there he said
it like yoda he's our tour guide
our guide door
guy tour he is
i busted a casey i'm gonna probably did
i talk like that all the time backwards
all the time like that i talk yep that
like you do so it actually costs like
6.99
so i'm just gonna google it
the dome was covered in copper by paul
revere everyone was able to listen
a tough crowd tough crowd
you're competing with luca over there
come on
hey luka you want to read this
oh so this thing was actually
we're here at some famous cemetery where
sam adams is buried and across the
street at beantown pub this is the only
place
where you can drink a samuel adams
across the street from sam adams should
we do that
i'm down but then where is
[Music]
so new england
you gotta see this little alleyway right
here it literally
[Music]
british is actually harry potter
so it's been one hour since i last
recorded uh what are you what have we
been doing for the past hour we've been
going to the police station
why
i lost my wallet
and someone pick up my wallet and return
it to the police attended the police
there you go but they want to find us
fee so all the cash is gone
but everything else is there right yeah
that's good part of it is that i got all
my cards back
i don't know if i should thank that guy
or no
it could have been worse so i think you
should thank him good thing is that
before i came i was trying to get more
cash and put in my wallet
that and you didn't do that i did not do
it so
thanks thankful for that i didn't lose
more and also this morning they got a
parking ticket oh yeah no i got the
parking ticket you didn't vlog about
that yeah you literally got a parking
ticket
first night in boston i get a parking
ticket all right anyway so what are we
doing
tonight are eating at the oldest
continuing running restaurant in the
united states this is opening 18
26. you sure about that 18 26 i had to
double check i didn't really read it i
just read 18 something true and we're
about to have some oysters
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you